geht es nach ihnen maske werden wir
menschen den mars schon ziemlich bald
besiedeln können doch um diese vision
wirklichkeit werden zu lassen stehen uns
noch einige herausforderungen bevor und
damit auch die nasa mit durch einen
ideenwettbewerb denen die
us-weltraumbehörde ins leben gerufen hat
sollen die pläne für eine mars
besiedelung konkret da werden die fragen
lauten wie könnte eine nachhaltige
unterkunft für zukünftige maß bewohner
aussehen und wie genau könnten häuser
auf dem roten planeten gebaut werden
klick zum science fiction hier gibt es
täglich faszinieren des seins videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nicht herzlich willkommen viele masken
ja nicht nur der erste sein was sind
transporters es betrifft was ja durch
eine explosion der kuh dragon
zurückgeworfen wurde im letzten video
haben wir ja detailliert darüber
berichtet er will auch der erste auf dem
mars sein wir machen ja immer wieder
videos über die super ehrgeizigen pläne
von ihnen mass zu einer zukünftigen mars
besiedelung derzeit ist sein unternehmen
spacex jahr mit dem raumschiff starship
beschäftigt das etwa 100 menschen und
rund 100 tonnen fracht zum mars bringen
soll
starship ist knapp 55 meter hoch und
soll auf dem raketen träger namens
superheavy in den weltraum fliegen denn
geht es nach ihnen was kann lediglich
eine autarke statt auf dem roten
planeten das fortbestehen der menschheit
sichern doch nehmen wir mal an alle
fragen und unwägbarkeiten zum transport
der zukünftigen maß bewohner wären
gelöst und menschen könnten tatsächlich
sicher auf dem roten planeten gelangen
die nächste herausforderung wäre ja die
unterbringung der siedler damit sie
überhaupt ein dach über dem kopf haben
um genau diese fragestellung dreht sich
ein aktueller ideenwettbewerb der nasa
der mit einem gigantischen preisgeld von
rund zwei millionen us dollar also
umgerechnet etwa 1,8 millionen euro
dotiert ist die us-weltraumbehörde
möchte damit antworten auf folgende
fragen bekommen wie könnte ein habitat
auf dem roten planeten errichtet werden
aus welchen materialien könnten die
unterkünfte bestehen sind diese
materialien auf dem mars selbst zu
finden oder müssten sie vor ort 3d
gedruckt werden die vision der nasa ist
es einen 3d drucker zum mars zu schicken
und bereits im vorfeld ein lebensraum
für die zukünftigen master zu errichten
der wettbewerb selbst ist langfristig
angelegt
und erstreckt sich über mehrere jahre
jetzt hat die nase aber die drei
finalisten der smoothie printed habitat
challenge ausgewählt deren computer
modelle haben sich gegen acht andere
teilnehmer durchgesetzt und zwar unter
anderem in den bereichen ästhetik aufbau
und machbarkeit auf platz drei gelandet
ist ein team aus conneticut die designte
unterkunft namens mass incubator besteht
aus insgesamt vier räumen diese sind
durch brücken miteinander verbunden und
mit streben auf dem boden montiert es
handelt sich also um ein modulares
design wobei die kugeln ein fußball
ähnliches design aufweisen drei der vier
verbundenen kugeln sind für das
zusammenleben und die arbeit der mars
siedler und siedlerin vorgesehen hier
können sie sich aufhalten entspannen
oder sich im labor mit experimenten
beschäftigen im vierten raum mit fünf
fenstern könnten pflanzen angebaut
werden die beispielsweise als nahrung
dienen dieses gewächs aus soll
unabhängig von den anderen einheiten mit
süßwasser einem kühlsystem und eine art
heizung ausgestattet werden die
materialien die für den bau des mars
inkubators benötigt werden sind alle auf
der mars oberfläche vorhanden
beispielsweise regolith also mars sand
und das darunterliegende grundgestein
aus basalt polyethylen dagegen kommt
natürlicherweise nicht auf dem mars vor
kann aber laut der finalisten relativ
einfach durch die kombination von wasser
und co2 hergestellt werden dieses
material eignet sich besonders gut um
die kosmische strahlung abzuschirmen
eine insgesamt wirklich spacige
konstruktion auf platz zwei gelandet ist
das team das sich zuvor es nennt und aus
dem us-bundesstaat kansas kommt bei
ihrem design haben sich die macher und
macherinnen an der natur orientiert und
zwar an dem bau der bienen wappen so
sieht der entwurf eine modulare
wabenförmige bauweise vor
das team schlägt vor dass ihre
kuppelförmigen häuser von einem mobilen
rover gedruckt werden auch hier sollen
zum einen private räume für die
crew-mitglieder integriert werden
zum anderen aber auch laborräume zur
erforschung des mars auf platz eins
gelandet ist das team search plus s.com
ihr design des mars haus zeigt einen
hohen zylinderförmigen turm der mehrere
etagen beinhaltet sowohl eine künstliche
atmosphäre geschaffen werden
an den seiten und auf der oberseite sind
pölten förmige öffnung vorgesehen die
licht hinein fallen lassen
auch hier sind natürlich zum einen
privaten zum anderen dienstliche räumen
für die siedler und siedlerin vorgesehen
verteilt auf den verschiedenen ebenen
als material dient auch hier wieder
unter anderem reguliert und polyethylen
alle drei finalisten haben schon jetzt
ein preisgeld von etwa 27.000 euro
bekommen in einem weiteren schritt
sollen sie jetzt ein maßstabsgetreues
modell also ein echter größe in 3d druck
entwickeln schon bald also im mai 2009
10 soll dann der sieger bekanntgegeben
werden der noch mal 700.000 euro
abstaubt die nasa möchte die ideen und
wie es nicht nur für eine zukünftige
miss mars-mission nutzen sondern auch
bezüglich einer möglichen mond
besiedlung doch höchstwahrscheinlich ist
zunächst einmal der maßanzug
denn er ist aus verschiedenen gründen
tatsächlich ein planet auf dem man sich
leben theoretisch vorstellen kann
beispielsweise hat er zumindest eine
dünne atmosphäre die vor kosmischer
strahlung schützt zum anderen sind dort
die temperaturen hinnehmbar
und es gibt genug sonnenlicht das man
nutzen könnte zudem ist der tag nacht
rhythmus auf dem mars dem der erde sehr
ähnlich ein tag auf diesem planeten
dauert 24 stunden 39 minuten und 35
sekunden china plant maß kolonie da ist
also auch etwas im gange draufklicken
auf dieses video anschauen und natürlich
klicks um science-fiction abonnieren
falls das noch nicht getan haben sollte
und viele fragen nach dem rezept
newsletter dafür hier draufklicken bis
dann bleibt dran